San Francisco looks and feels like a big city, but it's actually quite small
It has a population of under a million and is only 47 square miles
But what it lacks in size it makes up for in price
San Francisco is amongst America's most expensive cities
The soaring cost of living and the injection of Silicon Valley money has led some people to claim that towns lost its soul
But have no fear is still plenty of mojo left by the bay
Welcomed to San Francisco
San Francisco is the cultural commercial and financial center of Northern, California
The city's reputation is built on its colorful history
It hosted The Beat Generation and the free love movement of the 60s and 70s and was the birthplace of pride
These days the bohemian dream is up against it
the average rent for a one-bedroom apartment is over three thousand dollars nearly four times the u.s. National average so
When checking out the city start by dodging the traffic and embracing your inner flower power by grabbing a bike
Although San Francisco's famed for its steep hills many parts of the city are actually relatively flat
Start your journey at Pier 39 and pay a visit to the seals
These guys turned up after the earthquake of 1989 and have stayed ever since
a
10-minute ride away is Chinatown. This is the oldest and second largest Chinatown in North America and
Despite all the city's rapid changes it remains unbowed
House of Nanking is famous for its delicious cuisine and direct service that some people might find a bit rude
But don't take it personally. It's all part of the experience
Another quick ride will get you from Chinatown to South of Market or
Soma this vast warehouse filled district is home to countless live workspaces
Red door coffee inside the 111 Mina Art Gallery is the perfect place to chill for a moment before heading into the heart of
the mission
The decades the mission was a middle-class immigrant Enclave, but it was steadily gentrified by hipsters starting in the 90s
Here you'll find some of the world's best burritos served up mission-style
De Korea El Castillo is one of the best
Don't let their lack of de coeur ward you off. This is the real deal
Now you're fueled up it's time to tackle the hills riding up to the Golden Gate Park is worth the effort
We'll pass buffaloes windmills the Academy of Arts and Science and the flower conservatory all on your way to the Pacific
Now kick your feet up in luxury at sutras cliff house
Stylish restaurant and lounge with stunning panoramic views perfect place to unwind and watch the sunset
You